we've got a bitcoin reserve risk uh and
this looks like it has just dropped off
a cliff since the beginning of 2021 uh
and is now pretty much in this in this
green area what is this measure and kind
of what does this tell you uh for
bitcoin reserve risk
yeah so i mean first off i just want to
say for anyone that missed it uh your
recent segment with with brent johnson
was fantastic uh he's one of the best
macro mines out there uh and it's just
kind of dollar milkshake theory and just
thesis and understanding of how the
global economy works is is almost second
to none so
check that out if you missed that just
right before me uh in terms of bitcoin
in terms of reserve risk uh you know a
lot of fun recently with the macro
environment i just pulled this up
reserve risk as kind of one of the more
advanced on-chain indicators and it
takes a lot of different variables that
we have with uh you know this public
blockchain data but essentially what it
is is it just takes price uh and
overlays it with huddlebank and
essentially what huddlebank is is just
the accumulate the accumulative
opportunity cost of hodlers
so every time the coins are hottled and
don't move uh you can kind of think of
that as like a pent up opportunity cost
and so when you have price the incentive
to sell
up against what is the huddle bank or
the you know the accumulative
opportunity cost of all the hodlers you
get this really interesting oscillator
that maps out the bitcoin cycles quite
well
um so now what do we see is we're kind
of in this this green zone for those i
can't see it's obviously a deep value
zone and it's just interesting to see
kind of you know the historical cycles
mapped out uh with with so much data
just kind of packed into one metric
got it and so when you then start to
think about this uh this type of metric
is it something that you can evaluate
just on its own or do you know i look at
a lot of these metrics and say hey deep
value is measured across metrics and
it's really important to kind of see you
know the the uh almost confirmation
across so many metrics or is it possible
just hey look i'm looking at this one
thing and it's telling me something
yeah so i mean i really love to take a
multi-faceted approach with the analysis
which is why sometimes i come up here
and only show on-chain data sometimes
you talk about bond yields and
currencies and the dollar index like
like brent johnson likes to talk about
um but with on-chain indicators you can
almost kind of compact all the different
variables into one right you can see
well hoggers are spending however
they're holding why well it could be
partly the macro environment it could be
partly because of a derivative margin
call it could be all these sorts of
things but net net right we can see you
know there's 19 million bitcoins out
there uh and these are moving these
aren't uh and when a lot of bitcoin are
being huddled which we're going to kind
of cover a little bit later in the show
and you know prices is really far down
historically and obviously past
performances is not indicative of future
results but historically it's been a
fantastic time to allocate to bitcoin
with size um so we're in one of those
moments and again you know nobody wants
to buy blood and everybody talks about
wanting to buy blood until it actually
comes
in you know 55 from the highs whatever
it may be uh it looks like one of those
times
got it uh when we start to look at
things like the percent supply of
bitcoin that's in profit you've got the
seven day moving average here uh again
falling off a cliff since the start of
2022 uh what is this telling you
yeah so i mean obviously we have you
have a lot of people saying
unprecedented macro environment we're
already in an s p 500 bear market only
have two rate hikes uh we're spiraling
towards a big recession how will bitcoin
do
the reality is that bitcoin and it's in
its own volatile monetization phase it's
it's kind of had these huge booming
busts beforehand so really even though
it you know it's multiple orders of
magnitude larger this cycle uh in the
realm of bitcoin itself it's nothing out
of the ordinary right if we if you want
to look back into the early early days
uh there was really only one global
exchange mount gox and it collapsed and
the price of bitcoin collapsed with it
and what happened it recovered just fine
right and you know a huge percent of the
circulating supply was underwater uh
from a dollar cost basis standpoint but
what happened it recovered weak hands
transferred to strong
and you know the resiliency of the
bitcoin network just continue to chug on
block by block so uh i love looking at
this data because we can kind of see
like hey uh you know 50 60 of the supply
is underwater right uh and oftentimes
when you get to these levels you see uh
the the top buyers capitulate further
right which which further drives down
the price uh so we're kind of you know
we're seeing a huge transfer of weak to
strong hands and we can see that with
the data with just so many people
underwater yeah it is uh it is
incredible to see something that is a
public narrative uh expressed in the
data i think that's one of the beauties
of bitcoin uh we have the bitcoin net
realized profit loss uh again i think
just showing exactly what you're talking
about here with
more and more people uh being in this
kind of uh lost position um what what is
this telling you if anything different
yeah so i forgot to label it but it's a
30-day moving average here so it smooths
it out a little bit and also you have on
one side a linear scale of the net
realized profit and loss and a
logarithmic scale and i like to use the
log scale the big one price just kind of
you know to map it out it's a little
easier to kind of see the cycle by cycle
moves but essentially this net realized
profit loss what we can see is when a
coin is acquired and obviously we can
see when that coin was moved and the
difference in those prices um so when
when the price is going parabolic you
see a ton of realized profit i acquire a
coin for a thousand dollars i move it at
ten thousand dollars i have a nine
thousand dollar realized profit maybe i
didn't actually sell the coin but just
in terms of launch analytics we like to
call that a realized profit and so what
we're seeing over the past month is
essentially the biggest uh capitulation
or the biggest uh series of realized
losses uh in absolute terms we've ever
seen um so you know nothing short of
historic here and obviously i mean it
makes sense given that bitcoin you know
previously a trillion dollar asset was
bigger than it's ever been uh but just
goes to show you just the size of this
move the magnitude of it and just how
much the market's absorbing at these
prices
yeah it's just i mean just
literally staggering when you see this
um another statistic that uh i spend a
lot of time looking at and i'm actually
surprised we're not hearing more people
talk about it right now uh is the
percent of the circulating supply that
has not moved in the last 12 months uh
we crossed over 12 million bitcoin uh
that hasn't moved in the last 12 months
and this only continues to go up and to
the right as a number what did you make
of this given kind of all of the other
volatility in the market that still such
a high percentage hasn't moved
yeah so i mean in terms of the on-chain
analytic the hodler uh metrics this is
probably one of the most simple which is
honestly why i like it the best they're
not the best but it's one of my
favorites
it's just so easy to kind of digest
and so this is showing in absolute terms
the amount of bitcoin that haven't moved
in a year it's at 12 million i think 470
000 bitcoin around 66 percent of the
circulating supply
this just goes to show you right bitcoin
is 55 off the highs unprecedented macro
environment people are worrying about a
recession and what's happening the
bitcoin hodlers i mean you can hear it
you can see it on twitter you can see
the sentiment of the hodlers that are
just relentless and they're have
unwavering conviction uh i'd like to
think of maybe us two in that cohort um
right they're not moving their coins and
then in fact they're buying more and so
if you think about just strip all of the
data everything else all the narratives
away you have an absolutely scarce asset
on the other side of it you have more
and more going into the hands of people
that are unwavering uh in their in their
conviction and not gonna sell onto the
market uh in the end only one thing
happens and so uh we're kind of living
through this and obviously the market's
consolidating but this is why bitcoin
always resolves to the upside following
these periods